well this was not on my bingo car for
2023 so from a hotel over the Las Vegas
Strip you already know what's going on
here a little update on Headline you
might have seen today apple is
officially officially going to be
supporting RCS on the iPhone starting
next year in 2024 big headline a lot of
waves it's been making but a couple
clarifications first of all it's not
going to solve the blue bubble versus
green bubble thing in the US that's
still going to be a thing here because
the key is it's being supported
alongside iMessage which is still the
blue bubble maybe they'll change the
color or something
but as far as features we'll get we
should have higher quality media when
texting an iPhone to an Android phone we
should have read receipts we should have
typing indicators the weird one though
now is there is no end to-end encryption
supported in this Universal profile that
apple is choosing to support but there
are also reports that they may be
working with the gsma to maybe add
encryption to this Universal profile by
the time it shows up in 2024 so we'll
see but RCS now on the iPhone soon